DEREK SLATER: I think
we'll get started.
Thanks, everybody, for coming.
My name's Derek Slater, and
I'm a Policy Manager on
Google's Public Policy team.
We're having this panel because
we get asked often,
what should developers be
thinking about in terms of
public policy and the legal
environment around them?
Rather than having us just talk
to you about what Google
thinks about, we wanted to
introduce you to a few other
people who are both working in
the space advocating on behalf
of developers and startups, as
well as helping developers and
startups engage with government
to improve
government and civic services.
So with that, I'm going to turn
it over to the leader of
your panel, Mike McGeary, who is
the Co-founder and Director
of Engine Advocacy, a group that
advocates on behalf of
startups in Washington.
Mike.
MIKE MCGEARY: Thanks, Derek.
Hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming out.
I will make you one promise as
we start this whole thing.
I know that I am keeping you
from the party, so I will be
prompt and we will make
this worth your time.
So with that, I'm
Mike McGeary.
I'm the Co-founder, Chief
Political Strategist for an
organization called
Engine Advocacy.
We're actually based here in San
Francisco, and what we do,
as Derek said, is connect the
startup community in the
United States to government
at the federal,
state, and local level.
And work to build more efficient
grassroots tools, so
that you, as a developer, an
engineer, or as a founding
entrepreneur of a company that's
growing can have more
of a stake and a voice
in a debate.
I want to make this a little
bit interactive, since it's
the end of the day.
So if you'll indulge me.
Tell me, how many people out
there have ever taken some
sort of political action
other than voting?
Everything from holding a sign,
to writing a letter to
your congressman, to going to
a city council meeting?
OK, that's a surprising
amount of you.
And that's very good.
For those of you here from
the US, how many of you
did that for SOPA?
OK.
That's good.
That's a lot of you.
I'm excited.
One of the reasons I ask that,
and why I think it's really
good to gauge that is for those
that remember what it
was like to go through this SOPA
debate here in the US, it
was really the beginning of,
I think, the next stage in
engaging people like you who
design and build products
every day in the political
process.
Because as your companies have
grown, and have taken root in
places beyond San Francisco,
and beyond New York, and in
cities all across the country,
it's become more important for
members of Congress, for people
at the White House, for
your mayor, for the governor,
for people in the legislature,
in the regulatory environment,
whatever it is, to hear your
perspective.
Because you have a distinct and
important economic impact
on what happens to the
wider economy.
That's a lot of what
we do with Engine.
We're going to talk a little
bit more about economic
impacts, and then about specific
issues and areas that
a lot of this panel that are
all much more learned and
smart than me.
So I'm going to let them
talk in a minute.
What we're all working on and
how you can get involved in
that and help shape
that debate.
But from an overarching
perspective, SOPA really
changed a lot of
things for us.
It was the first time a lot of
people all across the internet
stood up and said,
wait a minute.
This has a material impact
on me and my business.
And that's why this
is important.
The internet, as I like to say
a lot, especially with my
friends from Google, the
internet is the greatest and
most positive force for the
democratization of ideas in
the history of the world.
And we need to protect a free
and open internet, not least
because we need to be able
to exchange those ideas.
But because so many of you
are building products and
applications and businesses and
companies on that internet.
A lot of them right here
in the United States.
And those have an impact on your
community, on am economic
level, on a social level.
Going even deeper than that into
civic innovation, which
you're going to hear
about in a second.
And I think that it's important
to inject your voice
in a debate when--
if you have a two-person company
and you're working out
of that proverbial garage, I
promise that not one of you
would tell me your
third hire was a
government relations counsel.
It's probably another
developer.
And that's what you're
supposed to do.
So we're going to try
to make this easier.
We're going to give you some
tools to get more involved,
more deeply, talk about some
of the issues that are
happening here in the US.
For those of you who are here
from overseas, we'll talk
about global issues as well, and
want to hear from you and
some things like that.
There are some groups that are
forming all around the world
to do this that we're friendly
with, that we're working with.
So we'd love to hear and
talk more about that.
Want to make it an interactive
session.
We'll all going to do a
little introduction.
I'm going to ask some questions
to the panel.
And then we'll do a little
Q&A. There are two
microphones, and they've asked
me to have you stand up and
form an orderly queue so that we
can get those questions on
audio and video for perpetuity
to be shared forever.
But anyway, so thanks
all for being here.
That's my quick introduction.
I want to kind of go down the
panel and introduce you to who
we've got here.
First, to my left, we're really
privileged to have Jen
Pahlka with us who leads
Code for America.
My favorite part of what she
does is that it really allows
you guys, developers, building
companies, building
organizations--
with the nine seconds of free
time you have every week, you
can jump in and help make
your city smarter.
Or you can take some time and
really dive in and do that.
She's going to talk
more about that.
But talking a little bit about
civic innovation and what that
can mean and how that can be an
important step in building
stronger communities.
But Jen, tell us about Code for
America and what you're
working on.
JEN PAHLKA: It's a bad
idea to put me first.
MIKE MCGEARY: I know.
JEN PAHLKA: You want
to do that?
OK.
MIKE MCGEARY: Do you not
want me to do that?
JEN PAHLKA: Well, I always like
to pick it up after the--
MIKE MCGEARY: OK.
JEN PAHLKA: But I can do that.
Do you want me to do that?
MIKE MCGEARY: Sure.
JEN PAHLKA: OK.
It is on.
OK.
Thank you for that very
sweet introduction.
So I think you're going--
the reason I didn't want to go
first isn't that I'm shy.
Though, I'm less shy every
day these days.
I think we do sort of pick up
where others leave off, in the
sense that the first interface
that you are offered as a
citizen is a political
interface.
And the first thing you're
asked to do is vote.
You need to vote.
And then after you sort of vote,
and then things don't
necessarily turn out exactly
the way you'd like them to,
then you find other
ways to advocate.
And I think these guys are all
going to talk about some very
important ways that you need
to advocate beyond voting.
Where we come in is actually
beyond that.
So we're talking here
about policy.
And there are a lot of ways
in which policies
get written and passed.
And they may be even the
ones that you wanted.
And then somehow, it goes
wrong yet again.
Anyone hear--
Terry Gross-- actually, it
wasn't Terry Gross, but it was
Fresh Air last week, the guest
host talking about Dodd-Frank.
Frank-Dodd?
So we passed this piece of
legislation that is supposed
to address some of the ills from
the financial meltdown.
And a lot of people worked
really, really hard to get
this thing passed.
And I think there were a lot of
things right about it, some
things wrong about it.
But basically, it was sort
of doing the right thing.
And then, in the couple of years
since it's been passed,
it has now gone from the
political realm into the
bureaucratic realm, to be
implemented in government.
Those people that we call
bureaucrats, and we often use
that word with a bit
of contempt.
And I don't think that
is serving us well.
They have the very
difficult job of
actually making that real.
And in the years since it
was passed, most of the
protections that were in that
bill have been essentially
unwound and, as I
said, defanged.
So there is this critical gap,
I think, between the
intentions of policies and
the outcomes of policies.
The reason I'm starting with
that is I'll give you a firm
example from Code for
America's work.
We came into the city of
Philadelphia last year and we
had a team working
with the planners
there on the 2035 Plan.
This is the strategic plan that
will guide development
within Philadelphia for
several years to come.
And they need input.
They have a policy that says
they're supposed to get input
from a lot of different
citizens
about particular things.
Things like food deserts,
whether rail
lines should be extended.
But the policy allows
people to come in
and give that feedback.
Well, they have to
come in person at
6:30 on Thursday nights.
So the people that come and give
feedback to that plan are
not the people that they
need answers from.
They're not the people who
live in food deserts.
They're not the people taking
those rail lines.
And so the Code for
America fellows--
these are people who
take a year off.
In fact, one of them was a
Googler who took a year off
and came to work with
Code for America.
They built a very simple text
messaging platform.
They put posters up
around the city in
very particular places.
So if they were in a food desert
it said, please tell us
where you shop for groceries.
Text your answer to
this phone number.
A lot of people don't,
unfortunately, have internet
access in their homes
in Philadelphia.
And they don't even have
smartphones, but they do have
phones that can do SMS.
At the end of these rail lines
they said, would you take this
rail line if it were extended?
You'd text the answer in
and it would text you
back another answer.
Well, what if you had
to switch to a
different bus or something?
So you could get all
this feedback.
That's making what you're
doing actually meet the
intentions of the policy.
And I mean, there's a lot more
to say about Code for America,
and I think about different
ways that
we can affect policy.
But I thought I'd just start
with that as an example of how
it's really important not just
to think about politics and
voting as your interface
to government.
We're really talking about
getting under the hood.
The bureaucracy is the operating
system of our
government.
We need to get down
there, too.
DEREK SLATER: That's great.
Bureaucracy is an operating
system.
There's a concept.
But no, it's absolutely true.
And the work that you guys have
done-- that's a great
slice of life-- has
been great.
We're going to come back.
I've got a couple of good
questions there, but I want to
introduce next Kevin Callahan,
who is one of you, in ways
that the three of us are not.
I often say that I should be
barred from ever touching code
on anything that we do publicly
or privately,
frankly, in websites that
we build in my office.
But Kevin is the Technical
Co-founder of a business
called MapMyFitness.
And he's down in
Austin, Texas.
So why is he here on
a policy panel?
And Kevin, talk a little bit
about your experience and why
it matters to you as an
entrepreneur owning a growing
business, continuing
to grow in Austin.
So not in Silicon Valley,
not in New York.
Why it's important do you think
for someone like you to
be involved in policy?
KEVIN CALLAHAN: Thank
you, Mike.
So my name's Kevin.
I started my first website in
2005 because there was a joke
that I was too cheap
to buy a GPS watch.
And since then, we've grown to
about 100 people, 50 of which
are in Austin, Texas.
About 30 in Denver.
About 20 across the country.
And I had always thought that
I was a small businessperson
without a real voice in terms
of some of the policy that
affects me.
And so the reason I'm here is,
is I met Mike about a year
ago, and I learned about this
great organization called
Engine Advocacy.
And there were three reasons
that this organization really
sort of compelled me, A, to be a
member, but B, to sort of be
up here on stage talking
to you about my
experiences with Engine.
First was need.
As a technical co-founder, as
someone who was trying to grow
a business, we would eventually
run into some hurdles.
We kind of high-fived each other
when we got our first
lawsuit and we were named
next to Facebook
and Google and MapQuest.
Pretty soon, those high-fives
turned to tears as the
lawsuits keep coming.
But it was almost a
rite of passage.
You sort of get famous
enough to get sued.
And now it's getting involved
in pushing through
legislation, like the America
Invents Act, which radically
changed the system.
There's still a lot of work to
be done with the SHIELD Act,
which really puts the onus on
the loser of a lawsuit paying
your legal fees.
We've sort of fixed some of
these problems and it's
through Engine that I really
learned how to interact and
get my voice heard more.
The second was confidence.
I don't think prior to meeting
Mike and hearing his stories
about how he's worked with other
startup founders, other
technology companies my size,
that I would be able to sit
down at a table at dinner with
Senator Cornyn, who's one of
our senators in Texas, with
his legislative director.
Because they wanted to hear
about my opinions about
legislation, which was a really
amazing experience.
Mike was instrumental, or
Engine Advocacy was
instrumental in bringing Senator
Moran to the table at
South by, and sitting next to
him and having him talk about
his Startup Act 3.0, which
really tries to address some
of the broken things about our
immigration system and our
visa system.
And then the third
is education.
Like all of you, we get
inundated with news.
And how many different websites
can you go to kind of
really figure out the issues and
figure out what matters?
And Engine Advocacy really boils
down the issues to what
really matter to us as
developers, us as business
leaders, us as entrepreneurs.
And so it's really those three
issues that I'm gladly able to
come and sit up here in front of
you guys and just tell you
how much I love what Mike
and Engine is doing.
MIKE MCGEARY: He's not a
plant, I promise you.
Though, as I often say when
we're on panels together, I'm
just going to give you all
the money in my pocket.
So thanks, Kevin.
You touched on a couple issues
there that I think lead us
into you, Jeremy, in that
patent is something with
America Invents, and now SHIELD
and some other things
that I think a lot of people in
this room have either run
afoul of a patent troll.
Or if you haven't yet, as Kevin
says, maybe you haven't
graduated to the big boy level
of getting sued yet.
So hey, good luck.
But we're trying to
fix that, too.
And we're going to need a lot
of developer voices on that.
The other one is immigration.
And there's a woman named Lesa
Mitchell, who works for the
Kauffman Foundation,
who is awesome.
And also says, if you asked an
entrepreneur what their top
five policy area issues are--
and I'm relatively certain for
those of you from the US in this
room, you probably would
agree with this.
If you asked for the top five
answers on the board, the
first four would be immigration
and the fifth one
would probably be patent.
But it's those first four
is immigration.
All the way down to my left is
someone who's actually doing
something about it.
Is more than talk is action, and
comes from a place where
action means a lot
more than words.
And that's New York City.
Jeremy Robbins is a policy
advisor to Mayor Michael
Bloomberg of New York and runs
the partnership for A New
American Economy.
I'm not going to read
your whole bio.
I'll let you do that.
But he's also running something
called the March for
Innovation, which is a great way
to get involved on what's
happening with the immigration
debate here in the United
States and try to get more
entrepreneurial people that
are already here to be able to
stay and start business and
work for technology companies.
So Jeremy, tell us a little bit
about what you're doing in
March and things like that.
JEREMY ROBBINS: Thanks.
Thank you, Mike.
I'd be delighted to.
And so let me start where Mike
started, which is by asking a
couple questions.
And I think the first one is,
how many of you in this
audience, by a show of
hands, were born out
of the United States?
Keep your hands up.
How many of you have at least
one parent who was born
outside of the United States?
And now, how many of you work
at a company where at least
one key employee was born
outside the United States?
It's basically all of you.
And there are two good
reasons to ask that.
First is because it makes it
really, really obvious about
the economic importance
of immigration.
You are the cutting-edge
developers in the most
important innovation industry,
or one of the most important
innovation industries
in our economy.
And every single one of you
depends on immigrants or are
an immigrant yourself.
And if you look at what those
statistics are nationally, you
get 40% of our Fortune 500
companies were founded by an
immigrant or a child
of an immigrant.
If you look at innovation,
what's coming out of our top
universities, more than 3 out
of every 4 patents from our
top 10 universities have at
least one immigrant inventor
on the patent.
I mean, the numbers are
staggering when you think
about immigration.
But the second reason I asked
you to put up your hands is
because it means that almost all
of you have had first-hand
experience with our immigration
system, which I
assume also means you realize
how broken it is.
That if you want to come to
America, you want to start a
company and you want to hire
American workers, there's no
visa for you.
But if you want to come
here on a temporary
high-skilled visa--
well, it turns you're out of
luck because the year's supply
of high-skilled visas
was exhausted in
five days this year.
You're going to have to
wait till next April.
Immigration reform is something
that has been so
fundamentally important for our
economy for decades, but
we haven't gotten.
And the reality is that politics
moves in moments and
this is a moment.
Now, we have an immigration
system that was started, by
and large, the way it exists
today in 1965 when we were
watching black and white TVs.
And it makes absolutely no sense
in a global economy.
But this is a moment
for change.
This is a moment where there is
a comprehensive immigration
bill right now in the Senate,
a bill that has a very
legitimate chance of passage but
has a very, very difficult
road to becoming law.
And I think there's a natural
tendency for people to say,
well, what can I do?
That I'm just individual.
I don't know a senator.
I don't go to DC.
I don't understand how
politics works.
I think DC is broken.
I don't think there's anything
that my voice can do.
But that couldn't be further
than the truth.
This bill is not going to pass
unless people stand up.
And people can stand
up because people
care what you think.
You can speak collectively.
And especially when you talk
about social media and new
ways of communication,
you have an outsize
voice in this debate.
So that's why we started the
March for Innovation, which is
going to be the largest ever
virtual march on DC.
And we've been very proud to
partner with Engine Advocacy
since the very beginning.
This march is going
to kick off next
Wednesday and Thursday.
There's going to be a huge
two-day digital storm where
we're going to get leaders
from politics, from
technology, from media, from
entertainment, from sports, to
jump across every social media
platform, from Google
Hangouts, to Twitter Town
Halls, from Reddit AMAs.
Creating a storm everywhere
you're going to look, driving
people to
marchforinnovation.com, where
they can sign up to with one
click, use Twitter and
Facebook to call on their
senators for reform.
And we'll going to have a lot
of star power to lead this,
but the only way this works
is if we build an army.
Is if people stand
up individually.
People tell their friends.
People tweet about it.
People get involved.
And it's going to be
a great success.
It's going to be a great success
in no small part
because of Engine Advocacy and
because a lot of other groups
that have encouraged people
to get involved.
That have encouraged people to
know that you can actually
make a difference very easily.
And now that you all have nice
Chromebooks, you can actually
do it right now.
Or you can do it from
your mobile device.
You can go to
marchforinnovation.com right
now and sign up.
And then there are tools to tell
your friends, to queue up
your call for support, to get
involved, to tell your story,
and to be active so that next
week when we start this march,
we can have a huge difference.
And we will have a huge
difference, but it all starts
with signing up.
And so what we need more
of is we need more
people to get engaged.
We need more organizations, like
Engine Advocacy, which
are absolutely on the cutting
edge of both grassroots
organizing and of
policy thinking.
And so I thank you, Mike.
And I thank you, Google, for
having me here today, and for
this panel.
Because this is how
change starts.
So thank you.
MIKE MCGEARY: This is really
not a program length
commercial for Engine Advocacy.
I promise.
But thank you, Jeremy.
That's very nice.
I want to stay with you for a
minute because I want to ask--
we're sitting here at I/O. These
are the best developers
and engineers in the world.
So a virtual march.
OK.
What can people who are much
more technically savvy than
you or I do to be particularly
effective during this and
moving beyond into the wider
immigration fight through all
of our platforms on this?
And how do you think that could
translate into sort of
sustained movement to get
people involved as well?
JEREMY ROBBINS: It's
a great question.
And I think a lot of it, I'm
the wrong person to talk to
because I think I should be
learning more from you in the
sense that, if you look at why
SOPA/PIPA was such a big
success and--
I know I saw a lot of hands in
this audience that played a
big role in it.
It was a success because
people got creative.
People got active.
And it wasn't just Wikipedia
shutting down.
I think too often one of the
problems of SOPA/PIPA is that
the lesson that seems to be
learned, at least in the
media, is that Wikipedia shut
down for a day, and therefore,
the bill stopped.
That's not what happened.
What happened is that people,
like Michael McGeary and
people like you in the
audience went crazy.
You looked at what your
talents were.
Whether it was creating a Tumblr
storm, or getting viral
videos, or whatever you were
doing, it was figure out ways
to make it easier for people to
engage, to tell their story
in different ways, and to
get people involved.
And I think that, when we have
the smartest developers in the
world, many of them sitting
in this room.
It's about, what can you do
of your own initiative?
How can you--
maybe it's something
as simple as a Vine
video or animated GIF.
Maybe it's building
a web tool.
Maybe it's mocking up a website
or taking the widget
that you can download at
marchforinnovation.com and
iterating on that.
But there are a lot of ways
that we need smart people
coming up with creative
and smart solutions.
And I think this is where it
starts, is rooms like this.
MIKE MCGEARY: I think that's
one of the things that we
really work to do, is create a
platform where creative people
can go and do exactly that.
Because you and I, and the
rest of us, we're not the
smart ones all the time.
We're trying to create the
platform and get more people
involved to do exactly that.
I want to turn to Kevin
for a minute.
I want you to talk a little
bit more about your
experience, having dinner with
John Cornyn's legislative
director, as a businessperson,
who's a constituent as well.
And I want to use that as a
frame to talk about some of
the issues that you see coming
down the horizon that are
going to be specific to where
you see as a business going
beyond immigration and
things like that.
What would they have been
most interested in?
Take us inside that conversation
a little bit.
And what was it scary going in
and scary coming out, or was
it productive?
KEVIN CALLAHAN: No.
So it was tremendously
scary going in.
Here was this gentleman
that flew in from DC.
We spent the day touring Dell
and AMD and all these large
Fortune 50 companies,
or Fortune 500
companies here in Austin.
But then he just wanted to
unwind with a beer, talking to
someone who just sort of is
trying to grow a company.
And to understand what issues
were important to me.
And questions he was asking
was, A, Startup Act.
How does that really
sort of impact kind
of my role, my job?
And for me what it is,
is I live in Austin.
I have a growing company.
We doubled our size over
the past year.
I can't hire engineers.
If any of you want to move to
Austin, Texas, we're actually
hiring Python engineers.
MIKE MCGEARY: The barbecue
is really good.
KEVIN CALLAHAN: Yeah, the
barbecue is really good.
MIKE MCGEARY: Hot
in the summer.
KEVIN CALLAHAN: But yeah, so
the Immigration Act speaks
volume-- to me, as a person,
I actually grew up--
I lived in 12 different
countries growing up.
My father was State
Department.
I have friends all over the
world that never had the
opportunity to come and work
here because of our system.
So the JOBS Act or Startup Act
was really important to me.
Another really important
thing with me is--
or another topic we talked
about was the Electronic
Communication Privacy Act.
It's this 25-year-old act that
was put in place to deal with
electronic information.
And what that basically means
now is the government can take
your emails, if they say, well,
we've already assumed
you've read them, so then we
can use them, and use them
against you without any sort
of legal recourse.
So it's an outdated system.
But what that does to me, as a
small business owner, who a
lot with location data, who
deals a lot with health data--
not health data, but about you,
because of the health and
fitness apps we build, that
really sort of puts a burden
on us in terms of being able
to comply should that ever
happen to us.
And so the idea is, well, let me
start talking about it now.
Let me have the platform
to talk to a senator's
legislative aide, so that if he
ever gets in a position to
make a stance one way or
another, I know my voice has
sort of been added to
that conversation.
MIKE MCGEARY: And ECPA,
Electronic Communications
Privacy Act, in a lot of ways--
we talked after SOPA,
the next one was CISPA.
And that was about
cyber security.
In a lot of ways, ECPA actually
has even more, as
it's written now before it's
being amended, is more
detrimental consequences from a
Fourth Amendment standpoint
in the United States, in terms
of search and seizure of
online and private materials.
And so it's good to see that
they're started to get wind of
that and starting to ask
questions as well.
And hopefully, it's more
than it's been
cast in some circles.
Which is, well, if we change
this, you'll be able to share
what you watch on Netflix
on Facebook.
Because that also stops you from
doing that, oddly enough.
But there are some really
interesting Fourth Amendment
implications there.
So it's good to hear they're
working on that.
OK, Jen.
I know you didn't want me to
come to you first, so I
definitely want to come back to
you now and talk more about
the culture shift you're seeing
in cities around the
country and some of the things
that you've been able to do
there, first of all.
But in a two-part question,
because you guys made a really
brilliant hire recently in
hiring Catherine Bracy to do
Code for All.
If you guys don't follow @cbracy
on Twitter, make sure
you're doing that.
I'll get her a bunch of
followers right there.
She's running Code for
All and helping with
international strategy.
I know we've got a lot
of international
people in the room.
So if you could touch on that,
but then also just generally
like, where you've seen your own
advocacy take you, overall
and broadly?
And thinking about what Code for
American can do from that
perspective.
JEN PAHLKA: OK.
So Catherine, if you're
watching, we'll count that as
an announcement of
Code for All.
MIKE MCGEARY: Sorry.
JEN PAHLKA: It's cool.
She was hoping someone would.
MIKE MCGEARY: OK.
JEN PAHLKA: Agree,
she's brilliant.
You asked a couple questions
in there.
One is about the culture.
And I think that whatever
question you asked, it gives
me an opportunity to make a good
point, which is that Code
for America is about--
we create apps.
We work with governments, local
governments, on building
these apps.
The real outcome is that we're
using lean startup techniques.
We're using user-centered
design.
We're walking them through
a process that's vastly
different from how technology
is usually bought or built
within government.
And the process that they go
through with us is actually
more important than
the outcomes.
The outcomes have been
successful and so it's been
fun to be able to talk
about those.
But what we talk about less
often, because it's sort of
the follow-up question is, what
happens when somebody
who's a technology person in
government goes through this
process and sees that it is
possible to create an app in
three months, that if it'd gone
through their procurement
process would have taken--
these are not random numbers.
This is really from one
particular sample and we have
many like them.
A three-month app that we did
that they said would have
taken at least 2 years and
cost at least $2 million.
So that creates the political
will for change.
And the real outcome here is
the culture virus effect of
having someone go, oh my god,
we can do this differently.
I'm going to go talk to a whole
bunch of people, other
people who are on city
government and get them
excited about a different
way of doing things.
And to bring it back a little
bit though, I think to the
sort of advocacy piece, I'm
talking about the flip side of
what you guys are talking about
here, which is that the
people in, especially federal
government, they think they
know technology.
They talk to a lot of companies
that do technology.
And there's increasingly some
great people, great companies
that are serving
the government.
But there is an entrenched group
of companies there and
they're often not the kinds
of companies that
you people are starting.
And so they don't know
these issues.
And they're not getting the
benefit of the innovative
approaches that we see in
the startup community.
If the open question here
is, what is it?
How can your startup
influence policy?
This is the biggest
ask we can make.
And I'm not asking for your year
of your time as a fellow,
though we would love that too.
And we are recruiting for
fellows for 2014.
And it's an amazing,
amazing experience.
But the biggest ask, really
because that's a one-year time
limited thing, is start
a company that serves
government.
There are an enormous number of
opportunities to do that.
Think about the way we regulate
right now and
contrast it with how Matt
Cutts regulates spam and
search quality results.
We take three years to
change the law when--
by the time we change
the regulation,
it's completely outdated.
We need algorithmic
regulation.
There are companies that should
be built around that.
I don't want to go on because
this could take all day.
But there's a million great
companies that need to be
built that can serve
government.
And I know most of you think
about it, like no way in hell.
I'm not going to
go through that
two-year procurement process.
I want to make great product.
I don't want to work
on paperwork.
But the thing you need
to understand
is that that's changing.
It may be changing slowly
and me may be in the
beginning of it.
But part of this culture change
is the will to do
procurement differently,
to open the government
contracting system up to a
whole new set of vendors.
There's a great project
that was just
released called Procurio.
Or I think it was originally
called RFP-EZ, which allows
your average 30-person web
shop to bid on a federal
website contract.
Clay Johnson released this video
recently where he talked
about the fact that the
president just announced
initiative to map
the human brain.
And it's going to cost a hundred
million dollars.
We routinely spend something
like 150--
in this case, $188 million on
one government website.
Do you think you guys could do
a decent government website
for less than $188 million?
I think you probably could.
That's our money.
That's our taxpayer money.
And the benefit of it is if you
get in there and you're
working in government, then
our leaders in government
actually have an understanding
of the issues that you're
dealing with, too.
So it all comes together.
And this was a very long ad,
which I will wrap up for our
Code for America Accelerator,
which is accepting
applications through the
end of this month.
But there's a lot of different
ways that you can do it.
That's one important one.
MIKE MCGEARY: Well, and the most
interesting thing for me
with what Clay did with
RFP-EZ, which is
now Procurio, is--
that was a government program.
He was a presidential
innovation fellow.
He worked with Todd Park, the
US Chief Technology Officer.
It was in the White House.
It was a very much, very
structured program that's now
been spun out and has become
it's own private entity.
That's starting to now bleed
out and help people.
I've said this before I think,
but government's really good
at spending $100 million
or a billion
dollars of taxpayer money.
They're not really good
at spending $25,000.
And that's where, especially in
the kind of products that
you guys are all building,
that's where a lot of the meat
can really happen, where the
rubber can meet the road.
JEN PAHLKA: And by the way, two
of the Code for America
teams this year, in addition
to the other work they're
doing with their city
partners, are
implementing Procurio.
So we tie between what happens
at the local level and what
happens at the federal level.
MIKE MCGEARY: That's great.
That's encouraging to hear.
We've got a few minutes left.
So if there are questions, I'm
going to encourage you to run
up to-- oh, there
are questions.
This is fantastic.
So let's do that.
And then, we'll take a couple
questions and have some
closing remarks.
But I'll start at the front
microphone, the gentleman in
the green shirt.
AUDIENCE: So I have
to-- is this on?
So I have to piggyback on
that last conversation.
So from the opposite side of
the spectrum, so I'm a
technology professional within
the government, having the
problem of going through the
acquisition challenges of both
the FAR and the DFARS and other
types of legislation,
it's very, very difficult, even
if you work with the open
source advocates across the
community, to push out
capabilities so that you can
get people to work on it.
You can't get the money out to
be able to take multimillion
dollar programs and actually
make them efficient with
smaller teams across the
US or otherwise.
Do you know what's going on?
So I haven't heard of that
particular initiative.
Are there other things to be
looking into that there's
actually top cover of actually
changing the implementation of
the DFARS and so forth?
JEN PAHLKA: Federal Acquisition
Regulation, is that FAR?
AUDIENCE: So that's the FAR.
And then there's other nuanced
iterations of that.
JEN PAHLKA: So this, to me
again, this is the awkward--
you guys can answer, too.
This is the operating code that
is sort of bloated, that
we need to get at.
And we're not there yet.
I think where this movement
is, is proving that it can
work in a couple of
limited cases.
So Procurio really was built
just for one use case just to
start, which was a sort
of basic website.
It's got content.
It has a little bit
of interactivity.
It's probably pulling some
data from some database.
And anybody here could
probably do this.
What I would suggest--
so it starts to create that
conversation, which leads to
OK, these are laws
and regulations
that need to be changed.
But I would recommend for you,
in the situation that you're
at, to look at the Presidential
Innovation
Fellows program.
That's the way that Todd Park,
this federal CTO, and Steve
VanRoekel, the CIO, are trying
to pull these sort of
over-complicated processes
together and say, we're going
to create a little space
here for innovation.
We're going to take this process
and we're going to
say, we can do something with
this in six months.
We're going to have something
that works at the end of six
months, whether it kills us--
even if it kills us.
And then, from there you kind
of build back into, OK, how
does this now become a
sustainable thing that works
differently from the bloated
process that went before?
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Again, it's one of those things
where there's been a
lot of talk about this for a
number years across the actual
government circles.
Whether it be through different
CIO shops, or otherwise.
And curious how it's progressing
from the actual
community side outside
of that.
JEN PAHLKA: There's no one--
I'll try to be brief.
There is no one effort that
can fix everything.
I think, to your point before
about a platform that has
emergent outcomes, the best
thing that we know how to do--
and I wish we knew
how to fix this--
is to tell the stories that
create the political will for
change and create the
environment and opportunity
for other people to stand up and
say, this needs to change.
We're going to do this, too.
KEVIN CALLAHAN: Yeah.
And I'm a little bit of an
outsider in terms of
government process and
regulations, but I know with
Obama's executive order last
week mandating that all
government data is accessible,
machine readable, et cetera.
Depending on what your need,
Code for America actually has
brigades in cities.
And so if it's something that's
really important to you
and that you think you make a
big difference, contact the
local brigade and see when
their next hackathon is.
Because potentially, they could
prototype something out,
if whatever you're doing has
that type of data available
out in the wild.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MIKE MCGEARY: I want to go
to the back microphone.
We just do have a few minutes,
so we'll keep going.
Thanks for your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
My name is Mike, and I work
in political data in DC.
So I might be one of the
bad people here.
But one of the common threads
that you all were talking
about was it seems that there's
a big failure of being
able to connect citizens to
the people who can make
something actually happen,
whether or not it was the
bureaucrats, or the people
crafting legislation, or the
people who will end up voting
on legislation in the end,
trying to persuade them.
My question is, how
do we solve that?
MIKE MCGEARY: I want to just
briefly say-- and I guess
somehow, even growing up a Red
Sox fan, I turned into an
eternal optimist.
But I would say that more than
this being a moment of
failure, it's a moment
of opportunity.
That with the proliferation of
tools on the internet and
platforms that have been built,
there are numerous
different ways for you now to
take action to make that
system better.
Whether it's being a
presidential innovation fellow
at that level, or working with
your Code for America brigade,
or taking action on a political
issue, or working
with your local police
department to help them
understand the data that they
have that they don't
even know they have.
And how it can be
cross-referenced with public
health data to help make
your city stronger.
There are ways to do all of
this on the ones and zeros
level, and to build applications
off that in ways
they haven't before.
Procurio is a great way
to think about it.
And that now you can build that
and the city can purchase
it and use it.
Imagine that.
They just haven't been able
to do that before.
So less a moment of failure,
more a moment of opportunity.
I don't know if anybody else
has thoughts there?
KEVIN CALLAHAN: Yeah.
On a local level, you can
actually make more of an
impact than you think you can.
Because local level, you don't
necessarily have to solve a
federal issue if something
is local for you.
So just go to a city council
meeting and just start seeing
who's talking about what.
And just get involved.
JEN PAHLKA: We use the word
"conversation" a lot.
And I think it's important--
we're talking in some cases
about getting our elected
leaders to listen to us and
our bureaucrats to
listen to us.
And the other side of it is, are
we listening to the data?
Are we listening?
Are we playing that back?
And I think your example of
police data's a perfect one.
But there's a bunch of others.
That data is there.
When your local IT guy in your
town actually puts that data
out there, it is your job to
go listen to that data.
They are opening a conversation
with you.
Show up.
Look at it.
Do something with it.
We talk about, at Code for
America, that we're creating
interfaces to government that
are simple, beautiful, and
easy to use.
That actually is your role to
create those interfaces
because the average person goes
and looks at that data
and goes, what the WTF?
I don't know this stuff is.
But that is the start of a
conversation and we have to
meet those people halfway.
MIKE MCGEARY: I think we've
got time for one more, and
then we'll all be here for a
couple of minutes afterwards.
You can grab us individually.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm from Latin America.
I'm from Colombia, actually.
Well, our governments also have
a couple of stupid, and
crazy regulations like
SOPA and PIPA.
It's everywhere in Latin
America, Colombia, Venezuela,
Mexico, Chile.
If they copy, and just they want
to copy, even they are
not conscious about what
they are doing.
Will you suggest to create
like a union for Latin
American countries of people
like you increasing the
consciousness of entrepreneurs,
business
professionals, and general users
on the internet from
this kind of movement from our
governments that just want to
facilitate the [INAUDIBLE]
and censorship of our internet
in Latin America?
MIKE MCGEARY: There are groups
like that that are starting
all over the world every day.
We work particularly with groups
like Coalition for a
Digital Economy in the UK.
We just did something with
France Digitale in Western
Europe, this week as well.
And we work with groups in
Europe, Latin America, all
around the world that are
starting to get together.
They're in a little
bit nascent stage.
And of course, with the
individual political
situations in a lot of these
countries, that changes the
focus and the ability to engage
in a lot of ways.
But yeah, I would encourage
you to do exactly that.
Find the startups founders that
understand that there is
a direct impact, and that they
have that impact on the
economic forces at play in
government, on communities
themselves, and on government
at the highest level with
being able to do things like
make bureaucracies more
efficient and work for
the people more.
And if you get those people
together, and you're able to
galvanize them in a way that
allows them to think about
these issues and then take
action, that you really can
have an impact, no matter
where you are.
Again, that's a little bit of
the optimist in me, but there
are groups like that that
are forming every day.
If there's not one in Colombia
yet, I think you
ought to start it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MIKE MCGEARY: So two
quick things.
We got to wrap it up there.
They're going to kick us out.
Thank you all for being here.
We'll stick around and answer
questions individually.
And I am doing office hours
tomorrow, if you really want
to talk to me for any reason.
I'm at Google Developers
something.
Google Developers Group
at 11 o'clock.
And I will answer any random
questions you have, including
about Red Sox history
and optimism.
But thank you all
for being here.
I hope this was informative,
and enjoy the rest of I/O.